it's that time of year again when
everyone's gearing up for the big game
here are some Super Bowl party types
that everyone can relate to
[Music]
guy who's only there for the commercials
guys quiet the commercials are on the
bandwagon guy Cam Newton's my favorite
player a guy who's way too into it oh
come on ruff where's the flag guy who's
only there to make wacky profits I got
20 bucks says the kickoff goes out of
the stadium guy who gets way too drunk
oh so drug guy who thinks he's watching
the Stanley Cup come on Ref how's that
not icing guy who doesn't bring enough
guac guy who brings too much guac guac
who brings a guy guy who can't find the
TV where's the TV guy who can't find the
guy who can't find the TV where's the
guy that can't find the TV I found the
TV guy with really long legs who always
puts his feet up on the TV Amish guy who
brings all his kids and builds a house
in the background dead guy guy with a
cylindrical head really sophisticated
robot guy who nobody knows is a robot
guy guy who tries to jump on the couch
but he never lands girl who fuses with
the couch guy who's trapped in a jar of
pickles Oh pickle guy government agents
who come to take away pickle guy guy who
loses his memory from the agents who
memory flashed him after taking away
pickle guy guy where I'm on government
scientists guy who dissect pickle guy
ethically conflicted government science
guy who finds what they're doing to
pickle guy reprehensible but also knows
that the blood from pickle guy could
save thousands of lives
whistleblower guy who lets the world
know what the government is doing a
pickle guy guy who makes whistleblower
guy disappear and is also the guy who
didn't bring enough guac
credits guy logo guy
[Music]